i'm kim van allen doha with the
headlines on al jazeera
we begin with breaking news out of
afghanistan the taliban have just seized
a provincial capital as they make gains
throughout the country
our diplomatic editor james bayes joins
us now live from kabul james
what more do we know
well we have two eyewitnesses confirming
that the city of zoranj in south western
afghanistan
has fallen to the taliban that is the
provincial capital of
nimro's province and that would be the
first provincial capital to be in the
taliban's hands
i tell you the government say that they
are on the outskirts though of zarage
and battles continue but in the center
of the city we know that all the key
buildings
the governor's compound apparently they
surrendered there without
uh perhaps a bullet being fired i i'm
being told
uh the only building in the center of
zarage that is not under the taliban
control
is the office of the afghan intelligence
there they are still putting up a fight
it is a small province it's a desert
province but still significant the
taliban have taken
a provincial capital it would seem also
worth telling you that overnight
20 000 people reported to have fled from
nimrod's province
across the border into iran that's not
the only important
development in afghanistan in zhao zhan
province in the north in shebrogan the
stronghold of the
veteran commander general abdul
um abdul rashid dostum uh the uh
fighting is taking place and dostum's
palace
is now in the hands of the taliban and
here in kabul an important development
the deputy spokesman of the president
dawa khan manapal
has been killed while he was on his way
to friday prayers he was also the head
of the government media office the
taliban said he was killed as a
punishment for his actions
they said it was a special mujahedeen
mission we've already got reaction to
that the eu
envoy in afghanistan andreas von brandt
saying he was shocked and appalled by
yet another
heinous assassination very fast-moving
developments and for now
they all look to be in favor of the
taliban
all right we'll be checking back in with
you james for now james bayes
in kabul